all right good evening everyone welcome
to our lecture and our live streaming
show with with the that's what been
college but I ran out because I've been
here for three weeks I ran out of my
greatest losses I mean sorry but I
haven't lost to dozens of games that are
so painful I mean if I were if I were to
blunder more than 20 times in my life I
wasn't probably that good to become a
grandmaster but but so I turned my point
to critical moments because I love those
painful losses or hard ones happen but
miss critical moments so today tonight
I'm going to talk about critical moments
decision-making cognitive biases a
little bit and I bring for you from
grantee 2019 games that have played in
the past few days taking place in
culture over in in in Germany with
Carlson Caruana Island all the top
players and Vincent karma the Wonder Boy
from Germany who has a tough time lasted
all of his games but okay he he's
learning new things so and it's and
there are two games of his in this in
this episode but just I want to say that
I'm not trying to pick on the kid just
happens to fit in the magician material
so so talking about the complex and
critical moments what would define a
critical moment in chess what do you
think
well something on the only moves for
example right we can say the only moves
what else from the audience from live
anyone's live nothing's going on with
band business
what do you think critical moments in
chess mineralogical drop like decisive
moments when the game will be decided
but sometimes you just are worse and you
cannot improve the position that's on
our story but there are moments that you
can save the game to a draw or your
watch win the game you miss the winning
and all these moments these are critical
what else
turning points moving from one phase and
stage of a game to another moving from
the opening and you have your you're
almost done with your development and
it's time to you know what I'm gonna do
with my pieces it's a complex Sicilian
middle game or you know it's not always
a dragon where you castle dong and your
opponent Castle short and you know where
you're heading to our your opponent
knows more or less this can be more
complex so that's those turning forces
you have to make a decision and basic
base your decision on a plan a long-term
plan is that's how we think we are not
going to move by move our computers so I
picked a few points and I'll talk a
little bit about how we make decisions
and how our decisions could be biased or
not being biased so the first example I
this is quoted from Grand Master Thomas
looter from his book well I mean it's a
game that have been in different books
but I saw have happened to see it in his
work is that the obvious is not always
an answer what did we call obvious so
what we have a collection in our
memories or what seemed to be plausible
so let's look at this position of course
there are two results right what's not
gonna lose something the worst can
happen is that you promote I take it so
but this is this is a moment that either
black can save this position or is gonna
lose right
now let me give everyone three minutes
because we have also live audience and
their 20s there's a 20 seconds delay 20
seconds delay so camp black save this
position if so how
this is a calm day and is it a calm day
any comments yeah okay
why would you guys play
okay what's the follow by taking c5 okay
so you want to go King a freaking e -
what do you think King f3 King c5 and
then King III so what's your first move
what's your first King c5 okay all right
well we have two very interesting
answers well I do want to say which one
is right which maestro because you know
there are two different answers right
well one of them is right if I see if I
divulge that information then people who
are watching live do they would know the
answer right now
okay well event so where exactly on
defiled not the question is no the King
has to go to three so the first thing a
lot of people would say I'll push the
pawn f3 f2 well first of all if she
doesn't work and we are in time and then
the King goes to G - the King goes to
Ichiro comes to a font grabs the pot
doesn't work so so the obvious is not
always the answer the obvious is not
always the answer
so King goes to f3 and then white plays
King c5 so I make the sound the obvious
move is not always the right one so king
c5 now you have three choices on the
e-file you both gentlemen
you were right and was it who said on
the e-file Thomas was that who said put
the King on the e-file one okay you guys
are right
what there are three squares on the file
which one do you pick
and you've got III you stick to your
three yeah you already made up your mind
you can you know yeah an actual game you
have one choice to make right
you cannot go take back your move right
and he wants it now where do where do
they play kinky for kinky three or kinky
to just King says kinky to you got a
tough one thumbs up yeah okay what else
okay give another 30 seconds to this if
you have more comments and then I will
show the answer this was from a material
produced by Grandmaster Thomas tutor
someone has given it to me some of my
students and I saw a very high value
made the educational value in it and
then I've included in my lecture what
the reason is that the final position
will remind you of some very interesting
games who was in my lecture that I
talked about being Lear and again I have
to polish against England at night
versus rook here you guys here last week
the night for suspicion very nice is
recognized yeah yeah the night versus
rook you were dead okay all right so
because this kind of related to that one
okay any any comments spent shall go
shall we proceed
I'm waiting for you all right so the
actually write the score is King 2 e 3 E
- ante for our are losing before it's
too far
I'm sorry before it's to partnership too
far from the promotions for King c4f 3
okey one shake and then I bring my King
and it's going to be so that one was not
that hard to figure
but King it you the problem is I go King
D for F 3 I got ok to check and I'm
flicking G 3 that is the problem so here
here after King to eastery okay three
check where do we go
same problem King t4 f3 now we got Katie
for we got kinky for now we are
shouldering the king so the entire idea
of putting the king is that I stop the
king from getting close to the f1 and
gradually try to promote my pawn you see
the obvious is not always dancer again
pinky - I'm gonna put the king gear and
supports f1 that's the first thing you
think about but you have to think you
have to consider that King on c5 and you
have to avoid you have to you have to
shoulder left not to let it get close to
the f1 so after King to e4 okay for
Czech can give economic in progress so I
get a bring my king closer check now you
remember to polythene clear end f2
locate rook check and now we have to
promote tonight because because this is
of course to leads to checkmate and
those who are here or watched our video
last week we talked almost for 3/4 of
the class about this night end game so
even even though you found all these
good moves just the story new story just
began
I just won't put few more motion idea to
check and not g3 and then back
if you are watching this video try to
perfect your your defensive technique
about this position because when you go
over the board and you don't have enough
time to act
you have to act based on based on your
memory and memoria can be confusing it
can fool you you can you can you may not
have memorized the right way you may
have condensed the difficulty of this
position to its elements which makes it
inept your knowledge so don't do that
learn it by hand the technique like
playing over the board play police games
against your friends over the board not
online not against against an engine or
something and then once it happens over
the body you win don't think your hand
just does what it's supposed to do your
hand will do what's supposed to do sorry
all right
now you might say that okay this was
okay something it may not happen in the
game I actually witnessed one didn't
happen to me well I witnessed one and
that was not a good one happened to ray
drops of 2011 World Cup let me show you
that one a very interesting game any
comment
so so ray at the time was not sorry I'm
going to adjust immediately it's gonna
kill me for this
yeah he plays say I should play in this
cranky open but he's now solid 2680 yeah
kind of performed that at that level so
but you know Ray was up and coming and
then this came against back row so they
drew their classical games and he lost
the first very lost the first rapid but
then won the second one with the Kings
gambit beautiful game and then he was
back and this is game this is Game five
now so two draws and then this is Game
five
so Ray was defending very well this
distant game should be a draw the
easiest way to make a draw is that after
king d2 is to play of 65 actually that's
the best way to make a draw sorry
f6 and g5 year so you give a check King
g3 can give 6 ok it now now the plan is
to get my king to a7 give up the pawn
and then try to move the rook and then
promote the a pawn in the meantime you
have to create a counter play on the
other side rather you start you start
grabbing some material right and then
for the past fumble blacks King should
be active so since black should become
active what should be what should i
black smoke here here I made a mistake
again the obvious is that objects are
giving a check because that ok it makes
a difference
well King f5 has has a problem King if
I've had the problem can't remember what
it was
but the thing is that King Johnny Five
that's an odd square I didn't think
about that one but then I can go king t3
you cannot get too far because you
cannot take the pawn f2 after king g5 if
you go kinky five king gifted King III
I'm sorry they cannot take this pawn
because I can give a check and then
promote so but I think can get five this
check is a still fine but then it's it's
time to act to act kind of we have to do
something proactive now as as black we
have to do we have to take me we have to
take drastic measures why because the
king is heading to b6 I cannot bring my
King on the other side of $2 of his
board I cannot just do that as black as
diff as a defender such as something
here he made a mistake he played the
move again the obvious the fastest way
to get to the a a 2 2 f2 pawn is to
attack it right so I use my rope but
that is to Tempe to grab the pawn and I
still have to activate my King to be
able to capture to be able to promote my
pawn to create a 3d and still create a
path problem and to and to promote right
like the previous game right you end up
giving this rook for the PI you'll have
a pass spot and then it's going to be a
draw right makes sense everyone here so
here the best move is king - people are
okay - Kings if I he took he the best
was to play King f5 now it's okay to
just play King f5 kingi for King
yesterday I'm taking with it with the
with the King I don't know why that my
notes are not here I'm just livid ah
I don't know what my thoughts are not
here here yeah did the best is this one
let me let me show you mine and try to
play from memory so I can go here and
here
here and lasso giving checks
and that can take this pot
or if or if
I go there there was a small trick here
I can I can actually play here here and
then maybe here then I take this take
and then if I if I for example ate this
move just you cannot just take this
punch for because of okay for [ __ ] so
you just can wait with the rock here
nice and raw
now you want to take on each foreign
it's gonna be a draw you see I cannot do
that because if I take here there's rook
a rook check I look here now but then I
have this check something's off here
King see six rupee eight but maybe we
are we are in time maybe it because our
I go to go King be eight I don't know
let's just look at it let's just look at
it well I mean I don't what's that well
I mean let's see let's see what happens
you this h4 now this this is a draw
it's the draw maybe this is not the
problem that maybe you can't just take
it actually anyways the point is
activating the king that was the point
so now after this move after after this
route k2 which is a mistake king c5 rook
takes f2 now what is winning now because
we are many Tempe behind with our king
but there's only one way to win this
position now actually if someone finds
this I mean bench we should give them
some gives us this serrated tougher why
to play
so what does white want to do but this
black want to go excuse me can you get
five kimchi for f6g five pressing pass
by King d6 I can go king rook a to this
is for white well I'm a king b6 to the
white move
that is I think Roxy it is what I'll get
is what what bar update okay that's the
right idea you want to get the rock
there may be for you and III and then
push the a pond okay King be six I go
broke f3 King gay 7 I mean look most
check and I take it this the problem is
that your king cannot leave so let's say
I mean I can do that just
actually you wanna play maybe dis move
then I start getting checks right
this
and actually wait a second the reptile
rock f3 here I don't need to do that I
can go can get five because a7 is a draw
so you have to move the roof somewhere
the syrup c8 and I get a cell giving
checks and now I'm active enough to make
it wrong
if rook c3 f6 g5 and then pass fastball
it's going to be drawn
if it was that easy I promise you he
would have seen it
huh what's that is why tomorrow okay
because I have to cover some more games
and I would like to allocate enough time
to all the materials I have prepared for
tonight I'm gonna show you the movies
rook F a double exclam anybody should
said that well the point is that this
pins down the King to the to the pond
so now after after okay to dare check
there you get to the level square King
g7 the thing is now you cannot go King
at five I take the pot right I take the
pawn and or I mean do I have to take the
pawn actually no I don't have to take
the pawn
yeah I can do that actually this
and I go here yeah when I go King p7 and
now I preserved an extra pawn and
there's no passport here yeah I have the
bridge and in the meantime I'm defending
the pawn match for which puts me in a
winning position but that's a very
valuable temple this true cafe I
actually didn't know about it until a 1
year ago I looked at this game again for
its educational value and I was like oh
my God look at that yeah but well but
it's just that the temple will let me
let me just show you the idea one more
time just so well after look to f8 yeah
again the obvious is not the answer
ok took king b6 rugby - so the point is
that if if I go King g7 trying to you
know dismiss the rope I win a temple so
by the time you start you start pushing
the pawn with the King on the 7 I'm not
on g4 or not on g3 my pawn is already
about to be promoted so that's that's
that's just hopeless
are we good it was very beautiful I
think right so let's continue but let's
see where the drama is I mean you
haven't seen a drama yet so so I say
rapid game and this is a rapid a 15
minutes game because if they first
finished 1-1 in the 25 minutes game so
then would they play 15 minutes comes a
World Cup game so they struck t8 said
this is a draw now he's in time he's in
time I don't know if there's a win here
I doubt this if there's a win here I
doubt that but definitely this is not
the way that felt like this is not the
way
okay so far so good now here comes the
moment black to play wait wait a second
he they were just for looking at
something similar to this yes we were
but not the H part the H bar has its own
has its own contingencies for the first
thing is that if you end up with the
pond
unless fun h1 equals tonight is losing
because it will just get stuck in the
corner any comments
Black's fine what for black year
well I mean for white I would have just
if it was whiter movie I would have just
given a check well actually I don't know
if how can I do that but let me just
open a new board just explain it to you
in fact it would be interesting to it
has also educational value so if it was
black and it was white to move this
position he will just give a check King
gauge to King f2 and after this move you
can go okay here actually and then
that's it h2 work to a6 and that's my
next move
now if you go if you go up here then you
get mated oh well it doesn't go there
ah but if ya that's how it works so
that's that's gonna be easy
let's go back to our position all right
any comments man nothing okay hook to
you six check
now if kimchi - well this is this is the
same position right now the answer is
King f1 they're very are not obvious you
don't do that you don't put the king you
move move the King away from your pond
you're not supporting the promotion
Square but you are shouldering the king
you don't let the King to f2 that's the
entire idea that's a job and as a
general rule of thumb thanks to one of
the greatest coaches ever Mark the
baretsky we know that in his book a
little bit a little bit hard to read his
book in my opinion the best endgame
manual ever in my opinion but it's a bit
of a tedious task to read the entire
book but it's a must read for whoever
wants to become a good player he said
sort of sound like you you're always in
a safe zone you're always in the safe
zone if your king is ahead of your pawn
so just having that in mind you put your
you would think about Cohen kingi - even
if you're not sure about it but after he
played edge to check there and oops can
you have two now if you promote Queen
there will be a skewer okay six check
takes the Queen and he played night but
that night doesn't get anywhere that
night we need a IJ K maybe some more
files that that that would have saved
the night but not enough we don't have
we don't have any more files on the
right side unfortunately okay
so lesson number one and two the obvious
scoop is not the obvious the answer ii
know your position how do you learn your
position again what do you say about it
played over the board and learn a
technique over the board do not reduce
it to memorise ideas and the game will
not learn that that way play over the
board all right all right very well
now let's get to some some of the games
from cranky okay hmm okay starting easy
or difficult easy
well we have a voting going on we
haven't won 122 more roads I put my
person well let's start with this one
then first this is a game between which
they are not as black against Francisco
y ho the best Spanish flair for or a
couple of the decades I guess he was
world champion under 18 in 1999 I guess
or something so that's making number one
in his country so that's two decades
right something like that so II foresee
69 c35 wonder is it okay I'll tell you
services so negative 3 this is called
the two nights system against the
against the CARICOM so there are many
ways to play he played Bishop g4 h 3
takes Queen takes and then he's six so
black gave up his light square bishop
but now all of his pawns are on light
squares so since the bishop is gone
we're okay to do that right is they're
not worried about our Bishop turning bad
right so that is one problem yeah and
also the position is rather closed so
given given the fact that the position
is closed
we're not that worried about the power
of two bishops right all right so g3
Knight of 6 a 3
don't know why he played a three but I'm
sure he had he had a plan well I mean
one thing is that the three dollars
Bishop before so maybe he was preparing
them of d3 to prevent them of Bishop
before Bishop c5 d3 castle Bishop g2 97
so we she five times world champion one
of my legend as a kid I know he's a see
the legend but he will always be a
legend but for me and one of my heroes
let's put it that way one of my heroes
as a kid he just to it's very simple
bringing the pieces to their optimal
square and the miners first right we
still don't know and then castle now
which side of the board shall we play as
black Queen side right because White has
more space already well-established over
there and I was preparing to move f4
besides our plans on e6 that means we
have less space on the King side than
space on the Queen side with the pawn on
d5 we have more tendency to have more
space to or the Queen side right so the
other side of the board so he played b5
makes sense right
what's that what's like alright so I
went my plan is simple I want to go a
five before keep that night open the
lines because that's where I can play
that's where I have my pieces that's
where I have more space and now by by
playing this move b5 he getting even
more space right any comments or
questions ok Queen d1 was played I think
Queen e2 Oh
the funny story was that I actually have
seen had seen this game before it was
played in Brazil when I was a coach with
the back at a time the earring and your
theme and someone I was I was watching
the games and someone in some other
board not my player play the exact same
position that's very fine and that's the
only other game in the same position so
that was funny because I was this I was
like the air so to speak and then I was
like I've seen spirit of somebody I've
played it before I was like that's not
an important game but ok I was there
Queen D 1 Queen b6 so
ah it prevents t4 yep oh by the way I
did not analyze these with these games
with engine because we're talking about
critical moments with the way humans
should think right if you know the
answers we just oh that is so obvious
but that's not really the case you have
to understand it position yourself I
check for the blunder so the moves are
or I suppose the moves I put are blunder
free but they're not like so deep in
[ __ ] and just check that if it's not
losing immediately because of a blunder
or something so these are the ideas I
had personally so Queenie to an a5 I
like the way we should play first of all
Queen b6 controls d4 doesn't let them of
d4 happening and now a5 is gaining more
space so I like that
King catch one now why did why he play
King gauge from preparing him over for
and then here we should play the move d4
I'm not the big fan of this one although
it's very hard I I also don't have a
suggestion yet I did not manage to
convince myself that this is can be a
good move because after this and he
plays a five also by the way 91 is a is
a move but you know from b1 you have a
better future you lose more Tempe but
the knight gets to f3 right this will be
rerouted to after you of course after a
4 but whereas after d1 even if you go f4
and 9f to the knight is on the way of
your pieces whereas on f3 it can join
the assault with 95 right alright so
might be one any play d5 otherwise the
move if I buy my wife could be dangerous
f4 and then Bishop comes to you for
maybe eyeballing attacking on its 7 or
just simply the mover for so he played
be 5 10 9 - 2 was played okay Bishop d6
this is a very good drop back right we
have to free the C pawn to be pushed
now let's have it let's have a view of
this position it is transposing to a
form of Kings Indian pawn structure
right
with a very odd very hard piece
imbalance because usually in King's
Indian you have all the minor pieces on
the board here black space Bishop is
gone right on the other hand whites few
Tempe behind the attack and blacks
destruction is not optimal because that
not enough six if you go f4 f5 and then
g4 g5 click the kick easily right so
it's a little bit hard to judge but that
Bishop should you be dropped back
because you want to go see 5 c4 right
that's what that's what blacks plan is
do you open the C file so that's the
that's blacks plan so that makes sense
to me
f4 Queen c7 that Queen also should come
back F tix if I was really bad you just
take with the Bishop g4 and then you can
put the bishop on f4 event or you can
even take with the knight this sacrifice
doesn't do anything rook takes f6 so you
can do this move and then C file and
then you can create a very strong
blockade put it puts an end to White's
attack so so here
f5 was played I expected this moment
then he plays Knight b6 so you may say
oh wow well wait a second this nut is
moving away from the king side isn't it
supposed to stay there to help the King
to defend the King and computer might
disagree with me but I think this makes
more this makes sense because it
supports the most c4 when you go C 5 c4
supports the c-4 Square and freeze the
d7 King for the night and night from a
Frisco's to d7 so that when you go G 45
in that can go to t7 what we should be
worried about is that already the move
of five is committed so what attack is
start will start rolling so what was a
critical moment now I want to ask you
but what is the moment d4 or was it now
it's really hard to optimize here
because he has already committed to the
pawn structure change a lot so he has to
go by by the by the flow but he has to
go by ok I am going to place the pieces
a car according to the pawn structure so
the critic
moment was here one of the critical
moments in chairs that you always have
to remember or the are those moments
that you are changing the formation of
an apparent structure for both plus you
for both parties this was the critical
moment now do I have a recommendation
yet no but it seems what stack is
getting dangerous so at least d4 should
be looked at critically so now a 596 g4
c5 I don't know why he played Knight f3
I honestly from here until the end of
the game it's very hard for me to
understand what why he who is doing
because I think he takes his time too
much I would have gone g5 night to e
eight or nine fifty seven and then f6
and I wanna play Queen h5 now and if you
did go g6 I was thinking h4 h5 I don't
need my knife and then transfer the rope
that would be faster so I mean if if g6
I'm not sure if this is a good probably
is not h4 maybe he didn't like this move
h5 but didn't I think Bishop we have
three and then I can sack the bishop
well on Poisson is what black was
because now not the king is sits on that
seven maybe and this pawn is actually
underway although I'm not sure if even
that works because this not can this
this not can come here and attack so
even that is not clear to me so I was
thinking this would have been very
dangerous I am sure they both have seen
things and they're way better players
than I am but this looks very dangerous
to me so but he took his time he played
Knight f3 where how he played this move
I have not had a chance to looked at the
post game analysis they may both agree
that this is a dangerous but not only be
the knight on f3 even if you play g5
there is neither to five because not the
Queen has has been blocked by the has
been blocked by the knight on f3 so that
you cannot actually go g5 easily because
the night goes to h5 now and the stays
close to the King and creates a threat
and stops blacks attack
so see for right that makes sense so
what was the critical moment for white
g5 he had a series of four snobs if
there was he see a series of four snows
that's when you have to pause and think
one more time it said oh wait a second
that there are series of forced moves
this can lead to a maybe a forced win
for me because g 5 f6 this weekend
I mean well I should go back right II
cannot do anything about it otherwise
they will lose a piece so this is I'm
sure he spent a lot of time here but
this is again he couldn't come to to a
turn with the move g5 that's I have to
watch the video and then this to see
what he said about this move g5 but yeah
this is was the critical moment but the
next moves are kind of rather hard to
again G and I'm not g5 there is a
problem with 9-5 same play Bishop g5 97
but now okay
what is fully developed fine but you
need to espouse to breakthrough he
cannot do much with the pieces because
there isn't enough space to do I mean
all the scores are covered right and the
pawns are sitting still tight I mean
they haven't moved anywhere so he tries
something plenty of six and of course
I'll not play this is strong of g6 right
you don't let that after F takes G seven
happens which completely shatters the
blacks shoulder shelter so g6 Bishop h6
look FC 8 combines defense rook has to
move with the attack you want to play
c63 I hope to see Queen to c2 right this
is what we want to do alright if I if I
remove the Queen's of the board who is
winning black because Weiss attack is
gone and black is dominant on the Queen
side like it's winning on the Queen side
because so much space all the pieces are
ready to jump another CD CD that this is
core becomes weak right after cd32
cisco's
whatever after this moment is the score
becomes weak and
then just blacks pieces kind of roll on
and sit on those weaker scores I'm start
winning material deponent b2 and
everything so Knight g5 here comes the
key move that I think my alpha missed
now he's coming to checkmate Bishop g7
Cooney F to finish for coming for the
checkmate now everyone also our online
audience what did we should do he felt
the danger he sends the danger and found
a critical way to react
any comments
any questions
and very calm day
then lacks conveys it feels decent in
those days
just kidding suggest night 6 Network if
a tour of 6
so no Matt takes pawn Knight takes f6
no did the rook takes it off seven you
taken up seven years and the bish yeah
okay tell me I can I can address some of
them you guys have some time neither
faith okay that is a normal move yeah
okay what's that
well how many weak squares you have
that's the that's the critical thing you
have to understand that is the well if
you if someone looked it up in the game
that's a great job but good job everyone
good job
don't check again yes bishop f8 is the
move I love this move but the depth of
it I mean this is forced first of all
takes takes so h7 is protected now it
comes to g7 what is so beautiful about
Alan's idea is that well suppose I go
Queen f2 now it's like when you bow
suppose I go Queen f2 how do you avoid
I'm going to do I'm going to clean it
for Queen e86 and mate how do you stop
that
okay I take you tonight then I play f7
check and then after checkmate I'll have
six this time
so you cannot defend g7 what can you do
instead you know you see you get don't
focus on what is so obvious what is so
obviously that I want to defend g7 but
what are the ways to defend g7 they say
in in life to not eliminate a question
right face your problem tonight tonight
erase the problem but sometimes in chess
it works just erase the problem where
the problem is the pawn f6 right so I go
Knight pd7
Queen h4 okay six now if the king the
Queen goes to h6 I just take on f6 right
just in time
right
so face your problems in life but in
chess you can erase the problems that's
okay Queenie 197 same thing a4 okay he
tries to create some complications make
the water a bit muddy but okay takes
okay four and SCD three and okay amount
just dismisses the now if he goes Cooney
edge for you can just take and take on
f6 so removes all the problem once once
for all
neither 396 okay now can chose that four
squared G v square and after coinage for
just king get seven now the King has
enough space to defend himself
excellent play by or not and now look at
bishop on g2 now that we show is a
problem it is just a big fun
g 5 h 5 look back to anyone but now the
nights are very solid defending
everything and it's just it's time to
just go to his house till it takes me
sheriff one queen bee 392 and and what
one does is that just he takes away all
of the tricks and all over the counter
play he the position is winning
it just makes best monster now he went
for some complications may be his last
resource wire hole and he played this
one i was like okay i'm not interested
now take this one too he picked up two
pieces already right let me do it again
epic one two right I just counted the
pieces I was like I have enough I take
it takes
and he goes repeat she dismissed the
Queen he picks up this pawn too
now he's up upon he has two nice under
look so he has two knights a rook and
upon that is okay the Knights I was told
it's three and a half but okay let's go
v36
511 and the points 12 and the coin is
nice
so three pawns up that's enough to win
nah check King g7 Queen III check we
have to locate it the King has enough
show that he can defend himself
before take sticks op8
you see for King g7 and then it's time
to resign everything is going to fall
apart neither for check now but the
thing is that now this pawn is very
valuable then this town goes check this
one comes here black the King has a
shoulder and in the meantime we are
attacking - so everything is just
working perfectly all right very nice
game right good good very good
any questions Ben we have to address
enough all right so given the amount of
time we have I'm going to this one will
take some work
this one also is very beautiful it takes
some work I'm going to ask two simple
questions
so
all right so in this game night is
against Hitler the the German now
representing Azerbaijan play grandmas at
night which he didn't play really the
his best chess and this is one of the
rare lines in Spanish exchange and the
guy did this position black is very
comfortable he has a very nice bishop
sitting on c8 it can go P 65 Bishop e7
coming very strong and in particular the
move f5 is not possible right because
then it gives away this beautiful square
for the knight to go to e5 this should
be a different color when I do it this
with it okay yeah so both sides try to
improve it your position then be 693 a 5
well I think c5 is not good because
gives up the d5 score so he goes a5 rook
e1 Bishop e6 is trying to eliminate a
knight now so if it simplifies and white
really cannot push his pawns that the
game will be just balanced he goes nine
f2 is probably trying to play for for
the win so rook e8 a3 so decent move f6
preventing the movie 5 so leaders I
can't really make so much progress so
you could say it's approximately
balanced but somehow white starts to
self-destruct a little bit 92 Bishop e7
93 yeah well the night on g3 protects
the pawn on e4 but so it was doing it
was blink so when he was on c3 right so
I'm not sure what the where the
improvement is so maybe he just tries to
maneuver around see maybe going to a 5
so c5 now the night is not City to go to
d5 even if it was there you could just
capture with the bishop now in the past
three moves who improve this position
like well yes I think this was a
critical moment whether it's time for Y
to bail out and try to make a draw
because it's not worse or if he's up to
something he has to have a clear plan
because look at the next two most
Whiteside is on g3 I don't know what it
does right I mean it does the same job
as it was doing on c3 right
it doesn't really I mean this pause on a
g7 honest and h7 all these pawns are
well protected you're not going to get
to them and after c5 not at Bishop on b7
is a monster and black has improved his
pawn structure right because blacks may
problem in in in Spanish exchange is
that those crippled pause was like I
don't know if you know it or not but I
just asked you you know if I remove all
of the pieces except me I mean if you
just walk right into the opponent game
white is winning right you know that so
given this position with all those
pieces on the board the fact that black
is pushing the pawns and creating some
plans maybe you can end up trading some
pawns and then the endgame would not be
that bad for you so now that five Queen
f7 rook to d1 or I cannot play Knight to
e7 of course but I can go neither fate
protecting the seven Square and now he's
playing just to kick the night with g6 I
told you if I wasn't a it was not a an
outpost so now but now look at this the
night on f8 will go to e6 which is a
nicer score than g6 right because it's
central so c3 okay now there's also this
whole in here which the Queen has access
to right
so this this move covers because not
after GC okay he play for first to fix
the position but not what the main
problem the main plant behind this most
c3 was to do what after g6 Knight moves
96th and I cannot go to e4 right because
this was it was going to happen right
is that right so this this is supposed
to control the squirt what happens is
that now I have a I have a score to you
so black life is a 4y + - 3 and he plays
96 alright so far so good and he drops
the knight back to g3 can we say black
is the one who's playing in this
position
and why is that because he has pressure
against the white spawns and white
really cannot improve his white really
cannot improve his majority cannot
really push the pants right and he has
immediate targets the b2 point I mean I
can't go with the Queen to b3 I have the
knight attacking the pawn I have for the
bishop sitting nicely and the Knights
have no future these tonight's so move
Bishop sistex was played Rock d2 98 what
does it's not going to smoke I give it
exclam and then and then c4 and
attacking me for and everything
excellent maneuver so Bishop c6 this
regrouping idea was very excellent
Bishop c6 98 97 96 and it's very hard to
see if black and white can't do anything
about it
King gauge 296 Wow now we have a target
so if you want to decide on the critical
moment for black which soother
masterfully exploited is this moment
black is better because every piece in
blacks camp is better than white piece
and whites majority is crippled cannot
really go forward it's not crippled is
it's not efficient and now it's time for
black to regroup when you don't see an
immediate idea you have to regroup your
pieces for the certain task and here
masterful Bishop c6 first the 98 97 96
improved the night and this leads to
almost a winning position that one he
found the critical moment Ziegler Bishop
c6 rock d2 98 2397 King gauge 296 like
it should everything Rock d1 and now
what's wrong with you
rook rook p1
then I go for example
came back to g1
well the night and this is also targets
which is square e for right so so did
not only salsa targets DD for square
right so what can we do about the four
square
well whatever the defenders the
nighttime g3 the night enough to the
queen and III right which these which
one is the easiest target the night and
g3 right h5 so simple yeah but effective
rook e1 h 4 so now look at you just
watch pieces and think about how well
they were placed 12 months ago they were
on c3 and f3 and look at the nights now
Queen b3 attacking be to e5 kind of
desperation F tech c5f takes e5 and
Queen takes p2 now
whoops I can you can take on this 61 is
pinned rookie 2 and then came back to b5
and I still cannot take on d6
Queen c2 and now we go nicely for not
upon a 3 will collapse and the position
is losing after each 693 White's
resigned
beautiful masterpiece really positional
play right improving positions
slightly in Bishop c6 98 97 was very
nice very nice see how he managed to
improve the night from g6 to d6 so what
was the missing moment for for for the
missing moment for white he had - yeah -
I think bail out in this moment when
they when let's go back he had to in
this mother of six he had to think about
if he goes with 93 and he takes he takes
with a C pawn if that's okay or not and
it's kind of balanced or or some other
ways because if he stays for too long he
cannot improve his position and you see
what happened to his position you see
what hap it was not easy to make it move
make it make it simple move for white
after this because how do you improve
your position and he tried to sit and
wait but he just gradually went down
right
but black had the plan but why didn't
have a plan whites only plan is the
majority by the majority was already
being stopped so the critical moment was
I think I think is this moment when okay
the pieces are fine
should I put the knight on d3 or not or
if I want to improve maybe I should put
this nut on f2 somehow I don't know like
maybe playing this then maybe like this
maybe write what you can of f3 hmm so I
think it to talk about the cognitive
biases maybe next time I come back to
st. Louis these are my last days he has
the gym resident but next time I'll come
back maybe we'll talk about it that was
what you mean the idea behind the a4
yeah well the thing is which moment this
moment you're talking well now's it
black/white is not trying to play before
to which woman here
well I'm trying to play Quinn before and
kind of messing with you with the pawn
structure over there so it prevents them
of Quinn before now but this moment also
I forgot to mention one thing
c3 not only controls d4 but also prefers
the move before that's why he played a
four it kind of fixed the pawn structure
yeah that's why he stops the move before
they're all right any certain questions
to address no sir
okay well thank you for joining me
tonight and have a good rest of the
night take
you
[Music]
you